ونحييكم الى التفاصيل بعد سنوات من التوتر
فتحت مصافحه بين رئيس تركيا رجب طيب
اردوغان ونظيره المصريه عبد الفتاح السيسي
الاسبوع الماضي فتحت الباب امام موجه من
لقاءات الدبلوماسيه غير المعلنه بين
مسؤوليا المخابرات في البلدين وفقرايترز
وزير الخارجيه
التركيين في انقره اننا تركيا ومصر قد
تستني فن العلاقات الدبلوماسيه الكامله
وتعيدان تعيين سفيان في العصفور المقبله
وقال جاويش اوغلو ان البلدين قد تستني فن
المشورات الدبلوماسيه بقياده نائب وزرايا
الخارجيه في ايطاليا عمليه التطبيعه قريبا
الى جنتك تصريحات قناه مصدر اقليميه مطلع
عنا وفدين من المخابرات التلتقي في مصر
مطلع الاسبوع وان مناقشات مهمه بدات
بينهما وانه من المقرر ان تبدا تركيا ومصر
محدثات حول القضايا العسكريه والسياسيه
والتجاريه
كده لك مشاريع الطاقه ولم يعلق مسؤولون
اتراك عندما سئلوا عن الاجتماع في مصر ولم
ترد وزاره الخارجيه المصريه من جهتها ايضا
عندما طلب منها التعليق بحسب وكاله
اخباريه
نناقش هذا التطور مع ضيوفنا من اسطنبول
دكتور سمير صالحه الاستاذ في العلاقات
الدوليه اهلا بكم من القاهره الدكتور سمير
غطاس سمير رئيس منتدى الشرق الاوسط
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا بكم
الكريمين هذه في الواقعه الحلقه الثانيه
من نفس الموضوع كنت معنا بعد المصافحه
التي اطلق عليها وصفت بتاريخيه بين
الرئيسين اردوغان والسيسي واليوم سنتابع
ما كنا نقشناه ويبدو ااه استاذ غطاس بان
الاستاذ صالحه وكانه كسب الرهان لانه كان
اكثر ايجابيه وتوقع ان تكون هناك متابعه
لما بعد المصالحه لماذا تستغرق الاستاذ
غطاس لم ااه الا ترى بان هناك ما بعد هذه
المصافحه وبدات الخطوط تتشكل شيئا فشيئا
يعني لم تقل ابدا ان المصافحه لم تاتي على
جديد قلنا انها خطوه للامام لكنها لا تعني
الانتقال الى اتفاق وما يزال في تقديري
وما زلت اصر على ان الطريق الى اتمام
المصالحه او التطبيع ما يزال في خطواته
الاولى التمهيديه لا احد يرفض التطبيع
بالعكس فان مصر لم اكرر مره اخرى ومره
يعني اؤكد ما قلته سابقا مصر لم تبدا على
الاطلاق ولم يسجل في تاريخها اي سلوك اداء
اتجاه تركيا والعكس هو الصحيح وبالتالي
فانه الكره بلغه الاولمبياد يعني الان
باللغه المباريات الكاس فان الكره ما تزال
في الملعب التركي هناك همم بالتاكيد خطوات
تمهيديه مهمه للغايه ومتفائله لكنها ما
تزال بانتظار اجوبه من الجانب التركي على
ثلاث ملفات اساسيه ملف قرارات وليس فقط
كلام قرارات بشان ما يتعلق بملف الاخوان
المسلمين في ليس في تركيا فقط الاخوان
المسلمين المصريين في تركيا والاخوان
المسلمين في ليبيا وهذه النقطه لم نتطرق
اليها في النقاش السابق الملف الثاني هو
المياه الاقليميه الاقتصاديه ومساله ترسيم
الحدود الاقتصاديه البحريه بين البلدين
والمساله الثالثه هي الملف الليبي
وبالتالي في هذه المسائل الثلاثه مصر ما
تزال بانتظار قرارات تركيا في هذه الملفات
الثلاثه وليس فقط يعني تتمنى ان تسفر
المباحثات عن قرارات تركيا في هذه الملفات
الثلاثه لانه ليس لدى مصر ليس لدى تركيا
اي استحقاقات على الجانب المصري ليس
مطلوبا من الجانب المصري لا ان يجيب على
اسئله ولا ان يقدم شيئا غير الذي قدمه
طوال السنوات الماضيه من 13 حتى 22
في ذلك هل الكره الان همم عند الجانب
التركي او كما تقول انقره همم الكره لدى
القاهره ونحن تقدمنا بخطوات حسنيه وننتظر
كذلك تفاعلا من جهه مصر
صحيح مساء الخير للجميع اولا همم ابدا من
النهايه همم خلال ثلاثه ايام فقط كان
عندنا ثلاث همم
تصريحات لقيادات السياسيه تركيا الرئيس
اردوغان نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد ووزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود شهر اوغلو كما
تبعتي انت ايضا كل هذه التصريحات تصب في
مكان واحد همم
انطلاق عجلات الحوار التركي المصري
وفي رغبه حقيقيه باتجاه التطبيع تسريع
عمليات
الجهاز المصالحه والدخول في نقاشات ثنائيه
جديده بين البلدين النقطه الاهم كما
تتذكرين الاسبوع المنصرم تحدث انه
سيناريو الاقراب قد يكون همم
وزاريه بشكل سريع تفتح الطريق امام قمه
بين الرئيسين كيوي المصري يبدو انه هذا
السيناريو مستمر يعني يبدو لي انا انه
الحوار نعم الان ربما على مره اخرى على
همم اساس اجهزه الاستخبارات في البلدين
لكن الرغبه الحقيقيه هي
زياره ربما لوزير الخارجيه المصري طبعا
نادي السيناريو من عندي حتى يعترض الدكتور
سمير ويعني يرى انه مستحيل هذا السيناريو
همم زياره وزير الخارجيه ال- همم المصري
سامح شكري الى انقره وتفاهمات على زياره
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان الى القاهره يعني
هذا الحوار في سيناريو من هذا النوع ممكن
ان يترجم عمليا في الاشهر المقبله لا يوجد
براي انا بعد الان اي تحفظات مصريات او
اعتراضات مصريات على مواقف كانت كانت
متشدده في السابق ولكن
اسمح لي ضيف يتحدث عن ثلاث ملفات شائكه
وثلاث ملفات تنتظر القاهره ردا وتفاعلا
بخصوصها من انقره نتحدث عن ملف الاخوان
تسليم بعض المعارضين الذين همم حكموا في
داخله المصري عن شرق المتوسط وعن ليبيا
ثلاث ملفات جد مهمه همم لتحصل لن ندخل في
تفاصيل الملفات يعني اسمحوا لي حتى همم
يعني همم نربح هذا الوقت في الحديث عن
العلاقه ومستقبلها ولكن هل تعتقد بانه
تسريع او ما ذكرت بانه وجوب تسريع همم
تطبيع هذه العلاقه سيتم حتى وان كانت هذه
الملفات معلقه
في نقطه اساسيه انه التقارب التركي المصري
لا يتطلب او ليس بالضروره ان يكون هناك
في كل الملفات هذه قاعده مهمه في العلاقات
الدوليه وفي الحوار الدبلوماسي بين الدول
تتفاهم في ملف تختلف في ملف اخر وغير ذلك
لذلك انا طبعا هذه الملفات مهمه واساسيه
اتفق مع الدكتور سمير لكن انا اذا عدنا
الى ملفات التي تتطلب هذا التنسيق
والتقارب والانفتاح التركي المصري ايه لا
تقل قيمه عن هذه الملفات الثلاث وهي كثيرا
متعدده نعم بينها موضوع الطاقه موضوع شرق
المتوسط لكن في ملفات ايضا الان تسير
باتجاه يتعارض مع رغبه ومن صالح الطرفين
وهذه نقطه اساسيه في الحوار الدكتور حطها
عن هذه الملفات عن مناقشتها عن همم
تاجيلها همم هل يمكن ان بس لذلك عائقا
امام تطبيقا كامل لهذه العلاقات خاصه لما
نستذكر بعض تصريحات المصريه تعلم حظرتك
بان همم اليد التركيه كانت ممدوده منذ
سنوات وفي 2021 كان البعض يتوقع بان يتم
تسريع تطبيع العلاقه ولكن كانت هناك
تصريحات مصريه في رد على اردوغان قالت لا
تصدق كثيرا فاقوال اردوغان قد تتعارض مع
افعاله هل يمكن بناء ثقه مع ملفات معلقه
يعني انا اعتقد انه تطبيع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه هذا شان لكنه لا يعني ان هناك
امكانيه للقفز على مسائل لا يمكن تكسير
الفجوه فيها بين الجانبين في ما ما يتعلق
مساله الاخوان المسلمين اذا يعني قبلنا
وجهه نظر التركيه على مدد وهي عدم تسليم
المطلوبين المحكومين بالاعدام رغم ان
القانون المصري ينص على اعاده محاكمه اي
اي شخص صدرت بحق هي احكام مره اخرى وقلت
في المره السابقه ان تركيا سلمت محمد عبد
الحفيظ حسين المتهم في قضيه اغتيال النائب
العام واعيدت محاكمته حتى اذا يعني همم
تركنا هذا مساله تسليم المتهمين ف- الامر
الذي يتعلق لا يمكن القفز عليه هو نصير
العلاقات التركيه بالاخوان المسلمين وقلت
ان هذه المساله لا تتعلق فقط
بالاخوان المسلمين في تركيا ولكن ايضا
بعلاقات تركيه بالاخوان المسلمين في ليبيا
وليبيا هي ملف لا يقل اهميه بالنسبه لمصر
عن ما تمثله العلاقات التركيه السوريه
وبالتالي يجب ان يكون تكون تركيا منسجمه
مع نفسها اذا كانت تعطي لنفسها الحق في
التدخل في الشان السوري الداخلي وتعقب ما
يسمى ب- اا يعني الجماعات الاكراد في
سوريا واحنا لا نوافق على هذا المساله على
هذه المساله لكن ايضا يجب ان تعرف في
ليبيا التركيه جيدا ان فيما يتعلق بليبيا
في ان هذا الملف لا يمكن القفز عليه تركيا
اجره اتفاقات مع حكومه غير شرعيه من
مزدوجين غير شرعيه في ليبيا لم تحصل على
موافقه مجلس النواب ولا هي حكومه منتخبه
هي تدعم موقف الاخوان المسلمين وتعقد
اتفاقات الاقتصاديه واتفقات فيما يتعلق
بالاستكشافات ال- الجهاز في المياه
الليبيه الاقتصاديه الى اخره ومع ذلك
وبالتالي فان في هناك يعني
مواقف تركيه لا يمكن القفز عليها يمكن
بالتاكيد ترطيب العلاقات الى ادنى حد
ويعني
التوتر ازاله التوتر دائما من العلاقات
واعاده التمثيل الدبلوماسي الى اخره لكن
هذا لا يعني ان نضع الغاما قابله للتفجر
في مسار العلاقات التي نتمنى جميعا في مصر
لم تقل ابدا انها ضد التطبيع بالعكس كما
اشرت في المره السابقه واكد مره ثانيه ان
العلاقات الاقتصاديه تزداد
النمو بثلاثه و30% في حجم التبادلات
التجاريه بين البلدين وبالتالي فانه مصر
لم تكن ابدا ضد تطبيع العلاقات لكن في نفس
الوقت في تقدير الشخص ايضا انه لا يمكن
القفز او تجاوز مسائل هامه شديده 100
بالنسبه للامن القومي لمصر تعليقك دكتور
صالحه خاصه واني اراك تكتب بعض الملاحظات
اكيد بان هناك نقاط ضد مهمه على ذكرى
دكتوره غطاس ان كان لك همم تحقيق وكيف
يفكر الجنب التركي كذلك في كل هذه النقاط
لي تعتبرها القاهره ضد مهمه لتغطيها
وللبناء عليها
صحيح يعني انا رايي الشخصي ايضا من خلال
المتابعه اظن انه موضوع الاخوان تم تثبيته
بشكل كبير جزء كبير من هذا النقاش في هذا
الملف تم حسمه بين همم البلدين لذلك نحن
في انقره كما تتابعين عندي ايضا تمنعوا
تتحدث عن هذا الملف حتى في جانب المصري
الامور بدات تذهب الاتجاه اخر بحث عن
ملفات عالي كربما بين الطرفين غير موضوع
الاخوان يعني هذا رايي الشخصي من خلال
المتابعه صحيح ربما في تفاصيل ايضا تناقش
لكن هيكليه هذا الملف برايي بشكل او باخر
الحوار التركي بالنسبه لموضوع انه في
اخوان في على ليبيا وعلى تركيا ايضا ان
تحدد موقفها هي هذه الاخوان هذه مساله
تعني انقره وتعني ليبيا اذا كان المقصود
شرعيه حكومه دبي يعني مصر واليونان هما لا
يعترف بهذه الحكم وهو بشرياتها جامعه
الدول العربيه الامم المتحده
بهذه تعترف بهذه الحكومه
وتنسخ معها وتفتح الابواب امامها وراينا
ذلك في قمه جامعه الدول العربيه الاخيره
الان في نقطه اهم اذا كان الموضوع الاخوان
في العالم الان سيطار تركيا بهذا الشكل
فهذا يعني انه لا يوجد رغبه مصريه من حوار
اليوم يقولون لنا ليبيا غدا سيكون لنا
يقولون لنا ماليزيا بعد ذلك نواكشوط وغير
ذلك
تصريحات المصريه كذلك تؤكد على اهميه هذا
الملف وضيف يقول لك بانه هناك بعض
التقديرات الغير الدقيقه دكتور هالطاس
يعني صحيح تماما هذه الحكومه التي عقدت
معها ليبيا كل الاتفاقات لم تحظى بموافقه
لا هي منتخبه اولا ولا تحظى بموافقه
البرلمان الليبي وهناك حكومه منافس لها
موجوده صراع الى ان يتم البث في ذلك عبر
انتخابات ديمقراطيه
علانيه ومشروعه وديموقراطيه يمكن الحديث
بعدها عن اتفاقات لكن اريد ان انتقل الى
نقطه هامه اريد ان اسمع الراي فيها اولا
مصر حافظت دائما خلافا لتركيا على مساله
المصالح الاقتصاديه المائيه لتركيا في
المتوسط مثلا العامل الماضي طرحت مصر
مناقصه على تسع مناطق 27 منطقه لكن منها
في البحر المتوسط حافظت مصر بدقه على
المصالح التركيه فيما يسمى بالجرف المائي
البحري التركي ومع ذلك وهي قابله ومستعده
لتوقيع اتفاق غدا حول همم تحديد المصالح
المائيه بين بلدين المشكله عند تركيا
تركيا لديها ثلاث مشاكل المشكله الاولى
انها لديها اختراع اسمه الوطن الازرق وهو
كل مياه محازيه لتركيا فهي جزء من الاراضي
التركيه وهذا موجود غير موجود غير عند
تركيا المساله الثانيه انها لم تعترف
بالقرار 1982 قرار الاممي الذي
يعني يتحدث عن الحدود المائيه المساله
الثالثه انها تريد ان تستبدل حدود ترسيم
حدودها المائيه وعناصر بالحدود المائيه
المصريه اليونانيه وهذا امر ايضا غير
مقبول ولا يجوز في العلاقات الدوليه انه
يعني همم اترك ترى
تسمح لي ضيق الوقت اترك الرد الاخير
وباختصار انت كرامته الدكتور صالحه
طيب ساختصر قدر الامكان ابدا من نقطه يعني
من النهايه موضوع اتفاقيه قانون البحار
مساله تعني داخل التركي لا احد يلزم تركيا
بتوقيع اتفاقيه تتعارض مع مصالحي هذا جزء
اساسي من اسس القانون الدولي العام
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى جانب 39
دوله في العالم الان تتحفظ على توقيع هذه
الاتفاقيه يعني من ليس من حق مصر ابدا ان
تسال عنقره ان توقع او لا توقع هذه النقطه
نتركها يا جانبا من الناحيه السياسيه
والناحيه القانونيه لا تعني القاهره هذه
الماده الان في موضوع ترسيم الحدود في شرق
المتوسط ان كان منذ ثلاث سنوات وتقول لي
انقره الترسيم الحدود بين الطرفين مربح
للقاهره اكثر تتحدث عن 20,000 متر فوائد
بكاسب بحريه لمصر الجانب المصري اختار همم
التوقيع اتفاقيته مع اليونان انا نحن نعرف
تماما انه القاهره
حمد مصالح تركيا البحريه اطلاقا لا اعتراض
على ذلك انا رايي الشخصي في المرحله
المقبله اتفاقيه ترسيم الحدود البحريه
التركيه المصريه هي التي ستفتح نقالها
جديد على مستوى المنطقه وليس منصه القاهره
الصناعيه التي وصلت الى طريق مسدود
وبرايين الدول التي كانت موجوده فيها
تتبعثر كل دوله على كل هو انتهى توقيت
الخاص بهذا الملف ولم نتحدث اصلا حتى عن
زياره
الوفدان من المخابرات همم
الاجتماعات التي حصلت ولم يعلق اي طرف
رسميا عليها على كل ربما سنناقش ذلك لاحقا
او الشكر لكم شكرا على المشاركه وما تفضل
به من اسطنبول دكتور سمير صالح العلاقه
الدوليه ومن القاهره دكتور سمير غطاس حيث
منتدى الشرق الاوسط الدراسات شكرا لكم